what's good everybody this is Aaron with
first we feast we're here today in
Madison Square Park Chris shake Shack's
10th anniversary celebration
chef Daniel home of Eleven Madison Park
made a burger today with truffles all
over it
today's burger drew the longest line in
Shake Shack history that's pretty
momentous how long have you been waiting
thus far in line what does it spend like
five hours now five hours Wow have you
ever lined up four other New York City
foods and waited a ridiculous amount of
time I ate a cronut did you wait for
that that was like an hour what were you
supposed to do today instead of being in
line for Shake Shack I suppose dude
let's go apartment hunting and if you
like push that back but I had a pretty
open schedule we got here at 10:30 time
is it now like for me here it's worth
the wait so from the people who've
already eaten it that's really good well
we have a basic hamburger topic courier
cheese bacon there's a little bit of
Bibb lettuce on there celery relish
which has an earthy tang to the burger
there's also black truffle mayonnaise on
there and then freshly shaved black
truffles too but they would you have pre
hot dog today
so we finally got a Daniel home Shake
Shack truffle burger and we're so
excited to try it let's see how it is
it's super super earthy with the trouble
in the truffle Mayo kind of like
lubricates it gives it that good like
extra juiciness the Gruyere works
perfectly it's so good and then the
celery relish is definitely that little
like brightness that it needs I bought
two of them and I was gonna give one to
a friend but I think I'm gonna eat the
boat I'm gluten-free but this burger
looks so good I have to try it I'm not
gonna eat the bread though oh yeah it's
really good I don't know if it's worth
six hours I'd waited probably like three
four hours for this so he came to the
10th anniversary celebration of Shake
Shack we got to try the Daniel whom
burger it had truffles all over it it
was so good
the real question here is would you
stand in line for six hours to try this
burger